hi there just thought i would update you
on my statistics before i get into my
talk today um so
my new known words total i'm i'm hoping
to get
if you look at my statistics i've got a
bunch of you know
targets there i don't know where they
came from i think uh the system
generates them based on
how you know how i define myself as a
learner
uh but in my own mind i want to get the
20 000 known words
which means i have to get about 700 new
known words a week
so i'm not at that level i'm 440 known
words this past week
and um the links come along naturally um
simply because i'm i'm getting new
content new podcasts
transcribed and i go through them and i
find lots of new words
but but my main objective is to get out
of those 50 000
or so saved links to try and convert
them to known
i often do that by going into my
vocabulary section and
looking at category two or even category
two and three words rather
and then moving those to known that i
already know but i haven't come across
them in texts yet to where i can move
them to known
uh one final thing you know the weather
is getting worse so i haven't been doing
as much because
the weather's been good and when the
weather is good i want to take advantage
and go and play golf
as you can see today the weather is not
so good
and when the weather is not so good then
it's an opportunity to do
more uh studying and
as we head into the colder season the
wetter season
hopefully you all will also have more
opportunity to
study your languages in my case it's
arabic so let's get on to
the video for today
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here and talking
again about language learning what do
you know
um remember if you enjoy these videos
and i hope you do because i want to
encourage people to learn languages
uh then please subscribe you can uh you
know
uh tap on the little bell to get
notified
and if you want to learn languages the
way i do come and join us at link
now what i want to talk about today is
the connection
between doing the dishes and learning
languages
all right most people don't think of
they think of learning languages they
got to go to school
or you know read grammar books
but i associate learning languages with
doing the dishes because
i would say that probably i spent more
time learning languages while doing the
dishes than
any other time because i shouldn't
say just doing the dishes also in the
kitchen because typically every morning
i prepare breakfast which consists of
starting the coffee the espresso machine
uh and then i chop up fruit
apples and sometimes we have berries
it might even be a mango and then on top
of that i sprinkle some
quick oats because the quick oats are uh
if you're gonna make muesli it's better
the quick oats than the slow
cooking oats which we would normally use
for oatmeal
i have to do that then i
i my wife makes sourdough bread so i
grab out the bread
grab the bread from the freezer and get
it to thaw out a bit so i can cut it up
so we can put that in the toaster
um anyway there's and then i borrow some
tea so there's a preparation period
there of
15 minutes or so i'm listening to my
arabic
so i listen to you know a podcast
i don't understand it i can't i'm
tantalized
because i know they're talking for
example i was listening to one this
morning
talking about uh netanyahu said
something at the knesset
about the you know the normalization of
relations with
um the united arab emirates
and now he his views on this and then
they interviewed
a palestinian and israeli arab and other
people and i'm getting
more and more of it but not really
totally understanding it so i'm
looking forward to then being able to
study that on
link so that listening with the dishes
gets me doing
going and of course the same thing
happens in the evening when my wife
cooks up a beautiful meal
and i clean up now the other connection
between the dishes
and learning languages is that there in
some ways
you know i thought about it the other
day when we finished our lovely meal
and i then walk into the kitchen and i
got this
you know i got pots and pans and glasses
and dishes
and stuff to put away and it looks like
a mess
but the fact is that you know it's not
gonna get
larger the mess it's not gonna get worse
so as i slowly start to put the salt and
the olive oil away and then i put some
things into the
fridge and then i i rinse the dishes off
before that
i put them into the dishwasher and then
slowly i get over to the
pots that might be full of grease and
that's a little more hard work with the
you know the steel wool or whatever to
get them clean
but it's slowly slowly getting less
i just have to one item at a time
attack the mess in the kitchen and i do
that of course while i'm listening to
whatever language i'm listening to but
it's the same with languages
you aren't going to get worse in the
language it's just
slowly you learn more you acquire more
words
you start to notice more things it
becomes a little clearer
and so it's that same idea that there is
a task there
that if you look at the entirety of the
task like starting a language from zero
it seems like a very daunting task or
the mess
particularly if we've had you know
nowadays any guests would just be
mark and his family over and you get all
those dishes to do
it looks like a lot but slowly just bit
by bit and the same with languages
little by little you put away more words
more phrases you notice things you
forget them you notice them again
but you aren't getting worse you're
slowly getting better
and particularly nowadays as i've
mentioned before
we're living in a world where the
technology is is
constantly making things better uh well
you know artificial intelligence i
mentioned now the automatic
transcription
of podcasts has become so accurate uh
and and of course you can go and you can
import it with timestamps you can import
from
youtube into link with timestamps
if you look at it in sentence view
you'll actually see you know the video
that matches the
sentence um
the whole world of language learning is
becoming so comfortable for people
and um you know right now they have the
sort of polyglot conference
virtual polyglot conference going on and
i've
visited a bit but
i noticed some of the comments there
were that they agree with me that the
word polyglot is a little bit
intimidating a lot of people don't know
what it means it sounds
like something very you know official
and serious and scientific
but really all we're talking about is
people who like to learn languages
and learning languages as i always say
it brings so many benefits
uh you know getting in touch with the
music of another language
getting in touch with the way of
thinking of another culture
uh meeting people of a different enviro
country and being able to relate to them
in
in a much in a closer way because you
speak the language
all these benefits and yet it's become
easier and easier to do
so again doing the dishes
bit of a humdrum task to that
extent language learning is not so harm
drum but it's the same
to the extent that little by little we
get better
and we don't get worse little by little
the kitchen gets cleaned
little by little we learn our languages
okay that's what i wanted to say thank
you for listening
bye for now
[Music]